[Musique]
un soir d'un terrible hiver il
chevauchait sous le maigre manteau d
officier romain
nous essayons de faire découvrir aux
enfants laventure scouts tel que l'ont
connu leurs aînés depuis maintenant 80
ans et à travers cette aventure ce coût
de ces jeux cette ambiance leur donner
un style et un style d'adultes puisque
le mouvement scout est un mouvement
d'éducation pour en faire des hommes et
des femmes pleinement chrétien est
pleinement ouverts aux autres
est ce que pour vous le scoutisme est un
loisir une pédagogie pour les enfants
c'est un loisir pour nous qui sommes les
adultes qui sommes qui faisons partie de
l'encadrement
c'est une pédagogie quelle est la
signification du noir et du blanc du
mousseau alors le noir sera signifie le
mal puis le blanc c'est la pureté mais
bien la lumière dit nous nous essayons
d'apporter aux enfants à travers des
jeux à travers des activités qui sont
adaptés à leur âge à leur cadre de vie
une éducation globale puisque nous
essayons dé duke est l'homme tout entier
et nous nous plaçons pour cela bien
entendu aux côtés de la famille qui est
pour nous la première éducatrice et nous
sommes donc des auxiliaires de la
famille à côté de l'école à côté du
catéchisme à côté de tous ceux qui
oeuvrent pour essayer de faire éclore
véritablement cet enfant est d'en faire
un homme ou une femme vie accomplie on a
senti qu on dit sceptique la loi scoute
et la promesse qu prononce tout garçon
qui désirent entrer véritablement dans
le scoutisme la loi scoute défi nit
positivement un certain nombre de
qualités que le scout accepte de faire
sienne et qu'il essaye d'intégrer dans
son existence tous les jours de sa vie
je m'engage à servir
mieux dieu l'église ma patrie et
l'europe à aider mon prochain en toutes
circonstances à observer la loi scoute
au 200 m fait partie de la grande
fraternité strictes je crois que toute
société tout peuple tout groupe se
reconnaît un certain nombre de coutume à
deschamps a des insignes des criques ans
et tribal ou aux les scouts doivent
découvrir progressivement qu'ils sont
crise de franches qu'ils sont qui font
partie d'une famille d'une communauté et
d'un certain nombre de communautés de
plus en plus importantes que sont leurs
donc leurs familles leurs sites et leurs
cravates leur pays l'europe et le monde
et ses différentes communes en leur
assignant leur signe de reconnaissance
que ses enfants découvrent en les vivant
on le recrutement des scouts s'est
toujours fait par les enfants eux-mêmes
en bonne partie autrement dit après en
avoir trouvé un ou deux ou trois qui ont
envie d'être scouts
lorsqu'on leur dit il faut être 8 pour
fonder une patrouille par exemple six ou
huit essayer de trouver les camarades
autour de vous en général ça ne traîne
pas et c'est eux qui font leur
recrutement
et lorsqu'une unité marche bias qui dieu
soit loué le cas de la beaucoup des
nôtres
le recrutement ne manquent pas bruno
depuis qu'en fait du scoutisme va
j'entame ma cinquième année et ça te
plait énormément oui c'est pour ça que
je continue
et pourquoi ça te plait tupaïa une
ambiance de camaraderie s'entend bien
tous ensemble puis
ça sort de l'ordinaire un peu disant
c'est toi même qui a choisi d'être
scouts au début non mais après j'ai vu
ça m'a plu et j'ai continué le mon plein
gré mais tu préfère passer tu étais
week-end ou des vacances avec tes
parents ou ici ou avec les scouts
donc c'est pas pareil et je préfèrerais
mettre ici parce que nous on est un peu
plus libre en hymne à la nature
depuis ces choses nous prenons les
enfants lorsque nous avons les chances
de les avoir dès le début de l'âge
d'éducation à 8 ans de 8 ans à 12 ans
environ il se trouve au louveteaux où
ils vivent dans le cadre de la meute qui
est défini comme la famille heureuse
autour de takeda chef du clan des loups
et où il découvre à travers les
personnages du livre de la jungle et des
jeux et des chants un certain nombre de
qualités il ya les amis de mme oublier
les ennemis de movie à travers ses
personnages il se vit se forgent leur
propre personne
à partir de 12 ans jusqu'à 16 ans et
demi 17 ans les garçons vivent à la
troupe dans le cadre d'une patrouille
que de noël définissant comme la bande
domestique est où se regroupent des
garçons donc les aînés ont environ 16 17
ans le chef de patrouille et les plus
jeunes 12 ans et les aînés doit
rapporter aux plus jeunes tout ce qu'ils
ont reçu eux mêmes sont déco éducateurs
pour côté de l'encadrement de la twa
monsieur galinier
comment schématiquement s'organise une
années de scoutisme chez vous j'écoute
est l'aboutissement de l'année scout
c'est le camp d'été alors si vous voulez
ce camp d'été comment se présente-t-il
il se présente en quatre phases une
première phase d'installation où on met
en oeuvre des techniques de froissartage
autrement dit de construction à base de
bois si possible ensuite une phase d'
aventure dans laquelle la patrouille qui
est comme vous le savez la cellule de
base du scoutisme part en exploration
part en exploration autrement dit à la
recherche des autres d'autrui ensuite le
grand jeu qui est aussi un moment de
gloire du camp de bucca en été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et enfin elle se retrouve ensuite envie
de trouver pour un certain nombre de
concours dans lesquels l'émulation entre
patrouille est mise à l'honneur et
scoutisme c'est un jour donc il est
manifeste que toutes les activités qui
en ressort
puis en comme base de jeu sont
certainement celles qui sont les plus
prisés par les scouts mais cela
n'empêche que dans ce jeu toutes les
techniques doivent jouer
[Rires]
[Musique]